I got two questions
for you, Utah.
Number one--
with all this repression,
can't you see why
you're watching so much porn?
And number two--
why are you paying for it?
(laughter)
-(applause)
-Hello? Doesn't make sense.
Okay.
All right, guys,
for more on this,
let's check in
with a concerned Utah resident.
Hi, Larry.
(cheering, applause)
WILMORE:
Hey.
-Hi.
-How you doing?
I'm Elder Masters.
Uh, hi, Elder Masters.
Hi, Larry!
-WILMORE: Oh. -It's me.
I'm Elder Johnson. Hi.
WILMORE:
Oh, hi.
Why are you guys
on a tandem bike?
It's the fastest way
to get around town
-to collect all this porn.
-Yes, right.
The filthy, filthy porn.
-BOTH: This is our mission!
-Uh...
Wait. Y-Your mission?
Oh, yeah. Larry,
seriously, I mean,
look at all this porn, man. It's
everywhere. It's disgusting.
WILMORE:
Wait, hold on a second,
so you're just
grabbing people's porn?
-We're doing God's will.
-Yeah. You wouldn't believe
-the haul we got from
the Romney compound. -Wait...
-Oh.
-Romney?
-Oh, my God.
-Mitt Romney?
Oh, dear God, yes, so much
filth, Larry. So much.
And also, Larry, true story--
we saw the image
of a man putting his hands
-under his own vestments.
-Oh!
Uh, do you...
you mean masturbating?
-I don't know.
-Yeah, I don't know.
-Whatever you call it.
Wait, guys. Have...
You've never masturbated,
have you?
No, no, no, no! Don't touch
down there. Oh, come on!
-God does not like that!
-It's okay, it's all right,
calm down, calm down.
It's okay.
Larry, did you know
missionary is an...
also a naughty position?
(laughs)
Sacrilegious.
Uh...
I-It's actually
not that naughty.
It's probably-it's probably
the least naughty of all...
Look, guys, it seems like
you're old enough
to know all this already.
You haven't...
You really haven't learned
anything by now, have you?
Hey, this is our... this is
a new world to us, Larry.
-It's a nasty, dirty world...
-Ugh, filthy.
...that is both repugnant
and exciting.
Okay. See, guys,
this is what I mean.
This is what happens when sex
is oppressed in societies.
You've been raised
to think it's all wrong.
(scoffs) It doesn't matter
what we think, Larry.
-It's what God thinks.
-That's right, that's right.
Jesus didn't use
his tinkle stick for sin. No.
-No, he didn't.
-No. Neither will we.
No, we won't.
Up until yesterday
we thought a blow job
is when you put your genitalia
underneath
a bathroom hand dryer.
Yeah. That-that does feel
very good, though.
-It feels amazing.
-Yeah.
-No, it doesn't, no, it doesn't.
-Uh, I don't think that's right.
You should try that,
uh, Dyson Airblade,
-it's amazing.
-Okay, let me ask you this...
Guys, guys.
Guys, so, what are you
gonna do with the porn,
um, after you confiscate it?
BOTH: I'm gonna
take it home and destroy it.
No, I'll take it home.
-No, I got it.
-I got if.
-No, I'll take it. -I-I should
take it. -Okay, I think I see
where this is going.
Elders Masters and Johnson.
-We'll be right back.
-I'm closer to God.
-♪ ♪
-(cheering, applause)